cette mère de famille traîne sa
séparation comme un boulet depuis déjà
plus de trois ans elle attend son
divorce comme une libération mais le
procès a été reporté en 2024
5 ans et demi de séparation c'est
horrible rien celle dans l'identité et
protégée par le tribunal a déjà dépensé
16000 dollars en frais d'avocat elle ne
peut pas vendre la maison et ne se sent
pas libre de refaire sa vie c'est
difficile quand ta vie tu n'arrives pas
à le contrôler elle est elle appartient
encore à mon mari elle appartient encore
au justice je n'arrive pas à vivre c'est
très très difficile son cas est loin
d'être unique c'est à Montréal ou la
situation est la plus grave en juin
dernier plus du quart des process civils
ont été reportés devant la Cour
supérieure faute de magistrats il y a eu
amélioration depuis le taux est descendu
à 5%. 12 postes de juge sont vacants à
la Cour supérieure soit près de 10% de
ses effectifs les causes criminels sont
aussi frappées de plein fouet la
pandémie a causé des retards difficiles
à rattraper
cette jeune femme a dénoncé son père il
y a 4 ans pour inceste le procès a été
reporté 5 fois notamment en raison de la
covid une ordonnance de non publication
interdit de l'identifier c'est comme un
camion de béton sur le dos
c'est énorme ce que ça fait à
l'intérieur de nous c'est énorme
avez-vous l'impression que le processus
judiciaire serait une libération oui
est-ce que ça a été le cas non pour
quelle raison
énormément long des jours d'anticipation
inutiles à se replonger dans l'horreur
chaque fois que le procès était reporté
de cette journée-là bon enfin ça va être
la fin on est comme un petit peu soulagé
on voit un petit peu la lumière au bout
du tunnel
depuis quand tu reçois le texto ou le
courriel ça te démolit comme une tempête
parfaite les démissions en cascade du
personnel de cours s'ajoute à la crise
226 postes sont vacances dans la
province ça adjointe à la magistrature
d'expérience qui se confie sur le
couvert de l'anonymat dit accomplir le
travail de quatre personnes pour moi
j'ai l'impression qu'on arrive pas loin
du brie de service et je trouve ça très
dangereux on est épuisé que ce soit
physiquement mais c'est surtout
moralement en fait parce qu'on manque de
reconnaissance décourager elles sont
déjà imité ses collègues démissionnaires
quand on regarde les salaires des
personnes qui travaillent aux
municipales ou aux fédéral des personnes
qui font la même chose que nous en fait
on a des différences de entre peut-être
5 et 10000 dollars au Québec environ 50
000 dossiers pourraient dépasser les
délais fixés par l'arrêt Jordan et menée
à des arrêts de procédures
la juge en chef de la Cour du Québec
réclame l'ajout de 41 juges après avoir
imposé une réforme qui augmente leur
temps de délibération c'est un véritable
bras de fer avec le ministre de la
Justice moi a donné des ressources
purementales à donner des jeux
supplémentaires effectivement mais faut
que ça se traduise par un gain
d'efficacité même les petites créances
ne sont pas épargnées il faut attendre
plus de deux ans pour obtenir un procès
devant cette division de la Cour du
Québec qui entend les litiges de 15000
dollars ou moins
une allégation de vice cachée sur une
moto devient pratiquement une saga
ce matin à 5h30 pour être si puis-je
faire dire que au pire pas de repas
d'audience aujourd'hui puis ça fait déjà
deux ans et demi qu'on attend Martin
en Floride pour être ici est-ce qu'ils
ne savait pas c'est que la faire avait
déjà été reporté mais il n'a pas été
avisé faute de personnel
la juge n'a pas caché son impatience
pendant l'audience on a un gros problème
de personnel et je suis très poli quand
j'ai dit problématique à tel affirmer
j'espérais finir aujourd'hui du côté
positif ou négatif puis passer à
d'autres choses mais là ça a l'air
pousser au mois d'avril c'est la juge en
chef du Québec refuse de parler de crise
dans le milieu judiciaire c'est une
terminologie certainement que qui ne me
plaît pas elle est consciente que le
système doit être amélioré nous
travaillons avec le ministère pour
s'assurer que les conditions de travail
de notre personnel soit revu demande au
public de ne pas perdre confiance envers
la justice et il est important pour les
Justiciers de comprendre que notre
système de justice fonctionne mais pour
certains il est déjà trop tard
ici Geneviève Garon Radio-Canada
Montréal